[Applause]
[Music]
Google Cloud's content delivery networks
CDN deliver a fast and Rich digital
experience for users and improves
critical business metrics let me show
you how for public facing digital
content CDN meaningfully improve
performance for user engagement SEO and
customer
satisfaction using Google Cloud CDN
Global Edge Networks users have the best
experience with your content Google
Cloud cdns are optimized for each
workload you can accelerate websites
videos including shorts user generated
content and
downloads originally built to serve
Google search Gmail and Maps Cloud CDN
caches static and dynamic content in the
closest of over 180 Network Edge
locations for content in Google Cloud's
compute engine cloud storage and gke
Cloud Cloud CDN is enabled in a few
steps and cash fill traverses Google's
performant and reliable private fiber
backbone on Prem or other clouds outside
of Google Cloud are supported as well
videos live or on demand and software
downloads require performance across a
longer delivery session for this type of
content media CDN leverages the same
infrastructure as YouTube with servers
in more than 1300 cities to serve
content at an unparalleled performance
and scale origin shielding with a deeply
tiered architecture ensures even less
frequently accessed content is cached
for longer this improves performance
across your Content Library and
mitigates origin costs Google Cloud CDN
provide Enterprise grade Edge security
protection and offer developer friendly
features like fine grain cache controls
realtime logging and metrics and
programmatic configurations via rest API
Google Cloud cons console and terraform
Google Cloud cdns use Google's
experience delivering services to
billions of global users to improve the
performance and reliability of your
website app videos and more it does this
by storing content closer to users
scaling to millions of concurrent
requests also achieving cost reductions
for
Eris when you're ready to accelerate
content delivery at the edge take a
minute to look at Google Cloud cdns to
learn more check out cloud.google.com
CDN